Isn't it weird that like pop corn became the official food watching movies.
Isn't that weird?
I know it's loud chewing shit.
He can't hear dialogue.
Have no one likes to say do the scope.
Let's go get some popcorn.
No one,
no one ever looks for popcorn unless they're at the movies.
That's a good point.
What is it?
Only time it's good.
Maybe a Disneyland because it's like,
Yay,
I forgot about popcorn.
Fucking and by that while I'm here too.
Other than that,
like the circus circus,
circus popcorn,
circus got peanuts into the mix.
Maybe there's something about the popcorn that like the,
it's like genetically modified and it's like it helps with the,
with the brainwashing just in the palm corn.
Yeah.
It probably opens you up to microwave dude.
That's what it is.
It just fucks with your head Bro.
Dude.
Basically microwave,
just kill everything.
Right.
When you might go into your food,
you basically just don't have anything.
It's just like,
yeah,
pop,
pop.
I'm nothing survived somewhere.
I can only write.
Isn't it crazy that we haven't really improved upon microwave?
It's like they mastered that shit 40 years ago and it's still the same goddamn
micro and it's really bad for you and they're going to take out of microwave
popcorn.
When you get microwave popcorn,
there's fats in there that your body just doesn't know what the fuck to do with.
That's where those things could sit on a shelf for so long and those little
packets I think.
What is it?
What is the toxic ingredient in microwave popcorn that they're eliminating?
It's hilarious.
They decided all this shit kills you,
but we're going to let you sell it for two more years.
They didn't just make it illegal.
They made a moratorium.
I think it's trans fats.
I think it just might be a vegetable.
Oil Fats.
There's certain certain trans fats that are just,
your body's just like,
what in the fuck is this non food?
Yeah,
you're,
you're making me.
Yeah.
We're talking about delicious protein bars before the show.
That gives you the most unbelievable farts.
That's how I know I shouldn't be eating.
So if I'm,
if I'm eating something and I'm just lightened the inside of my car on fire
chemical here it is chemicals used in the lining of microwaveable popcorn bags
including per fluoro [inaudible] acid or Pfo are part of a class of compounds
that may be linked to infertility in humans.
According to a recent study from Ucla and animal testing,
the chemicals caused liver cancer,
testicular cancer and pancreatic cancer.
So that's one thing,
but I know that they banned trans fats.
I might have conflated the two stories.
Did they?
Cause what is the ban of trans fats is the one where they're giving them like
all the like hostess cakes,
those bullshit cakes and the tongue sit on the shelf forever.
Ding dongs are my favorite.
Those things,
those,
those pop,
those pie cakes that you get from hosts,
it's like the lemon filling.
Those are just trans fats to the gills.
Twinkie method.
They last 20 years or whatever,
twinkie
twinkie.
You and I were laying around and fucking bored,
smoked a little weed,
watches some and up to God.
I'm so hungry.
When he got here,
man cabinet.
And you had like ring dings,
Twinkies and my grab a twinkie.
If I'm starving,
crowd watching survival chillin,
I might eat a twinkie.
These are like the worst wedding cake.
It says,
well,
you know what I had last night,
I had strawberry shortcake.
US popcorn makers could face long expensive road to lose trans fats.
Oh,
okay.
This is why I conflated it.
Microwave popcorn makers could face a long difficult task.
Ridding their snacks of trans fats,
US Food and Drug Administration proposal to ban the additive goes into effect.
So you s is banning.
So the u s ban on Trans Fats is what?
Um,
I uh,
what I got confused with that US ban on trans fats is like a dick given these
people like two years.
Isn't it crazy that they're there?
They're not big deal out of this.
They're going after the trans fats,
but they don't go after like,
like,
like real shit.
Like all calls,
like killing people all day,
every day.
I know,
right?
It's like you,
you say,
why don't you say this is going to kill you if you keep eating it,
but it's awesome.
But you're going after trans fats.
Someone,
someone in the popcorn industry just pissed off and an Illuminati mammogram.
You know when I go after him and this is this like a smear campaign,
trans fats.
People know they're bad for you once they know they're bad for you,
but should have,
be able to just take him.
What about the,
that one,
um,
drug that everyone's getting addicted to.
That's the legal,
uh,
Adderall.
No,
it's a Carolyn.
It's morphine.
Fentanyl.
No,
no.
Very,
very popular prescription.
Chicanx ECON.
Oh,
Oxycontin for sure.
Fuck your life up.
Hundred percent.
But he have serious pain.
It also leave Yeates pain.
And the thing is,
can you,
can you just it for a few niggling after trans fats here,
it's crazy.
Let,
let them have their popcorn.
Fuck Aa.
They're going,
they're making like news articles about it.
Who we're going after trans fat.
What about the 800 kids that go missing every year?
What about,
why don't you go well does it different?
People will look for that.
Okay,
that's true.
But these are different people.
These are food scientists.
But I think the point is that this stuff,
that there's other ways to make food,
but the thing is,
I don't know.
What is the benefits of Trans Fats?
Does it make processing easier?
Like why do they use that as opposed to like other healthy fats?
I Dunno why it probably has something to do with shelf life maybe.
Yes,
probably.
That's probably why it fucks you up to.